[Music]
are you confident are you gonna win this
case
Steve Owens from Miss Paltrow with his
presence a Stowe at Gwyneth took her
spot inside a Park City Utah court to
face off with this man 76 year old Terry
Sanderson who alleges in 2016 her out of
control scheme caused a hit-and-run
Collision leaving him with quote brain
injury four broken ribs and other
serious injuries
Sanderson is seeking more than three
hundred thousand dollars in Damages
Paltrow denies she was negligent and is
counter-suing for one dollar claiming he
hit her with a full body blow this is a
classic he said she said case so it'll
be sort of interesting to see who's
going to be the most believable plane
Tipper defendant here I do expect one of
culture to testify during the two-week
trial Gwynn's lawyer will also call
husband Brad falchuk and her two kids
apple and Moses as Witnesses Apple's
like what took you so long and she said
some
just ran into me but why put her family
through the hassle of a trial with an
estimated net worth of 200 million
settling for three hundred thousand
dollars wouldn't necessarily cause
financial hardship it almost feels like
as a matter of principle I'm not going
to pay you about because it wasn't my
fault and it sort of encourages the you
know the practice of bringing frivolous
lawsuits back in L.A Justice is blind
for Nick Lachey
the 49 year old has been ordered to
attend 52 weeks of anger management
classes and Alcoholics Anonymous
meetings stemming from that incident
with a female paparazzo back in March of
2022. but why you hit the window no I
think you're drunk I can smell yourself
there's been no new comment from Nick
who was out to dinner with wife Vanessa
at the time I'm a photographer I'm
looking for celebrities I thought you're
a celebrity Nick immediately owned up to
his behavior last year saying quote I
clearly overreacted I've been in this
game long enough to know that their
Antics are sadly part of the deal stupid
of me
awesome